what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay
so something that I thought would be
kind of cool here would be to run over
how Wolverines healing factor works
right because I think that's one of the
big questions people have going into the
Logan boobie why is Wolverine old if
Wolverine has a healing factor then how
can he age well that kind of also basic
question of how did he get to the
current age that he is right now if he's
had a healing factor the entire time
wouldn't he just stay a kid or whatever
age you happen to be when his healing
factor first kicked in so I want to say
that during Chris Claremont and Frank
Miller's original Wolverine mini
miniseries he's I think it was Chris
Claremont played Milich I believe they
established the ratio was something like
15 to 1 or 10 to 1 or something like
that
so for every 10 to 15 years the past
Wolverine only shows the outward signs
of aging by one year so his aging it
basically slowed down because of its
healing factor but the question is how
does that work like has that function
what's the whole deal here ok so let's
say that like you're shaving your face
if you're a man or you're shaving your
legs if you're a woman or you're shaving
your legs if you're a man and you're
shaving your face if you're a woman I
have no idea well let's say you're
shaving and you cut yourself what
happens okay it's a lot more complicated
I'm going to make it out to be but
essentially what happens is this the
body's immune system kicks in it clears
out any bacteria that may be prevalent
in the wound the red blood cells kick in
they begin creating something called
collagen which is the baseline for the
formation of new tissue new tissue in
turn begins to grow it fills in the cut
and then skin grows over that cut that's
basically what happens I mean there's a
lot more advanced and I'm not a biology
guy so you know but there's a lot more
stuff that goes into that but that's
essentially what happens if you sustain
a cut Wolverines healing factor does
much the same thing the difference is
that within the realm of mobile comics
it basically heals it perfectly where
your body heals imperfectly it is to say
you'll notice that if you cut yourself
and you have a scar it's because you
basically have new skin growing over the
old skin but even then it's imperfect
it's not perfect skin growing over
you're cut with wool brain it's
absolutely perfect skin because it's
healing patch are just functions that
way what what doesn't really tell us why
they just say that it does now the idea
here is if that's the case then are
there ways to basically get around
Wolverines healing factor the answer to
that question is yes there are three
main ways to do it
first way is to slow it down the second
way is to turn it off or the third way
is to get rid of it which is how we died
in the first place but with regards to
slowing its healing factor down this
comes by way of something called
carbonadium carbonadium is basically a
poor man's adamantium that's exactly
what it is when the United States
metallurgist modern MacLean accidentally
created adamantium Russia responded by
trying to create their own the issue is
they couldn't create adamantium
perfectly and so because of this they
ended up creating something called
carbonadium carbonadium is just like a
radioactive metal that slows down
healing factors it was just designed to
be introduced as a way to sort of add
this disability to neutralize wolverine
or to slow him down or create a way to
basically take him out to introduce a
new element to his stories they could
basically see him potentially being
defeated because up until that point he
was basically just this indestructible
man now the second way comes in the form
of the Muramasa blade and that basically
turns the healing factor off temporarily
the Muramasa blade was a sword that was
created by a man named Muramasa
specifically for wolverine at the
request of wolverine and the idea here
was that in his earlier days Wolverines
wife issue had been killed and in
response to this he wanted to eliminate
anybody that had anything to do with his
wife's death and so what he did is he
went to a guy named where amasa instead
crafting a sword that will do this
Muramasa took a portion of Wolverines
soul put it inside the sword and in
response to this anybody that's damaged
with this sword itself will have their
healing factor temporarily shut off for
a temporary amount of time and it
doesn't matter who that person is
anybody that can be penetrated by the
sword will have their healing factor
turned off so at that point all it
really comes down to its can the sword
penetrate their armor or something along
those lines now the idea here is that
once the healing factor is turned off
for a temporary amount of time well then
the issue is how do you kill will ring
because keep the body has an adamantium
skeleton so you can't just take a knife
and chop its head off it doesn't work
that way there really be no way to
decapitate war brain aside from some
super high intensity laser designed
specifically to cut through adamantium
or someone who can basically neo take
the adamantium office scallops in like
like magneto did which would just result
in will brain dying in the first place
because his body wouldn't heal but
regardless of the circumstances that's
one of the ways to basically nullify his
healing touch of the third way is to
introduce a biological contaminant and
that's what happened in Wolverine vol 5
and the story are called drowning Logan
it was a two-part story and it was a
prelude to the death of Wolverine and
what ended up happening is that in this
Woori will brain was infected with a
virus from a place called the Microverse
it's basically miniature universe those
of you guys who saw the movie ant-man
when he kept shrinking down at the very
end of the movie if he too kept going he
would have basically shrunk down to the
Microverse that's really what would have
happened this is extremely small
universe inside of the main Marvel
Universe but the idea here is that these
organisms you know this this biological
germ basically existed or at least found
itself within the main mobile universe
after escaping the Microverse with a
desire to eventually take over all life
to basically you know begin infesting
various individuals and then take over
existence as we knew it now of course
when they infected Wolverine the
organisms basically turned off his
healing factor they disabled it now if
those organisms were removed his healing
factor would have come back but while
they were there history in fact was
essentially gone and the result of this
is that Wolverine ended up dying after
being in Kayson adamantium that led to a
great big huge story art called the
death of Wolverine it was a great big
huge lead up the main story was only
four issues long but those are the ways
to basically turn it off now the
question is this going back to our
instance about how the body basically
reacts to any kind of physical injury
the question remains why does Wolverine
get old if those are the ways to turn
off this healing factor but we're not
talking about using those then how does
he age how does he get from you know
being twenty eight to thirty to forty to
fifty years old okay so what I want to
do here is I want to introduce two
characters named Professor X and Cyclops
you guys pretty much know who they are
but if you had never read a Marvel comic
in your life then there's a really good
chance that you believe that when it
comes to the character of Cyclops
that his eyes emit you know energy that
he's able to admit this concussive force
that can slice mountains in half and
knock people off your feet and make
Cyclops look really really cool but
that's actually not the case then Marvel
Comics cyclopses eyes are portals to a
dimension composed of pure energy and so
as long as he has the ability to open
and close his eyes his powers will
always be there those powers do not
degrade over time this same thing with
Charles Xavier and Marvel Comics there's
this idea when it comes to telepaths and
somehow they communicate directly with
each other which they do to a degree but
it's not that simple
and Marvel you have something called the
astral plane and the astral plane is
like this metaphysical realm or whatever
it is but everybody who thinks everybody
who has beliefs who has dreams and
nightmares or so on and so forth those
thoughts will radiate out into the end
of the astral plane and individuals who
have telepathy basically have the
ability to access that astral
so it would be like if you took all your
thoughts that you had everyday and you
want to take your thought and just drop
it off into a box a person with with
with telepathy basically has the ability
to go inside that box and to look at
your thoughts that's essentially what's
happening when it comes to the astral
plane telepathy and that kind of a thing
now people can do that in different ways
some individuals are born with an X gene
like Charles Xavier that allow them to
other people like dr. strange have magic
that allow them to but regardless
they're all able to do the same thing
but again so long as Charles Xavier is
not in a vegetative state that he has
full faculties of his brain he will
always have telepathy as long as those
powers aren't taken away from him the X
genes not shut down or something like
that now what this means is that the
powers of Cyclops the powers of Charles
Xavier do not degrade over time they
don't get weaker it's just those powers
will always be there Charles Xavier is
ability to utilize those powers may
decrease over time but his mind's
ability to access the astral plane will
always be - that door will always be
100% open Cyclops his abilities to use
his optic blast may decrease over time
in terms of how he chooses to use them
or what the case may be
but his ability to open and close his
eyes will always be there with Wolverine
it's not that way because of the fact
that his entire healing factor is rooted
on the body's biological system in terms
of how fast it responds to injuries as
he gets older his healing factor will
get slower it's the same reason for why
when you were eight years old and you
cut yourself your body would heal
extremely fast whereas if you are 91
years old and you cut yourself your body
would heal slower it's due to a
multitude of different things skin
elasticity your skin gets thinner it
stretches out further you know your
body's just older and so your systems
begin to slow down a little bit more you
know all those things kind of come
together to make Wolverine older now
again in terms of Marvel Comics with
regards to you know how fast all this
functions because of the fact that kids
his aging is slowed down it's the reason
why it takes so much longer for his
healing factor to slow down because he's
literally aging at a slower rate but it
doesn't change the fact that a time will
come when Wolverine will basically just
died of natural causes if he wasn't
killed artificially someone because of
the fact that he would reach an age a
thousand years into the future where his
healing factor would just burn out it
wouldn't be able to keep up with his
body's degrading state and he would
basically just die again it creates kind
of an interesting scenario with his
character but I want to go ahead and
throw this video out there and kind of
sense of the reason why it is that
Wolverine ages is simply because of the
fact that unlike individuals like Xavier
or individuals like Cyclops whose powers
do not you know degrade over time
Wolverines do Wolverines powers will
degrade over time because they're based
on his body's biological system it's
like Wolverine hitting a hammer you know
from the time his healing factor first
manifested up until the time when you
know up until right now
he's just been hitting a hammer but no
matter how strong he is no matter how
much energy he has a time will come when
his arm will just begin to tire out and
then eventually his on will just stop
that's how it's healing factor works is
after a while it'll just get slower and
slower and slower until it's just not
responding anymore so without being said
guys if you guys have any questions feel
free to post down in the comment section
also please try to help me talk if you
guys are new here to come as explain
make sure you hit the sub button to
become part of the rob Court if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]